I think we think that happiness is
something that you find or if you reach
some level in a company or school then
you're happier and what we're finding is
that happiness is not something that
happens to you
happiness is a work ethic there's
something that requires our brains
trained just like an athlete has to
train in order to become happier we
actually have to focus our brains down
on things that actually move us forward
instead of getting stagnating and the
things that for example stressing about
things are outside of our control
doesn't move us forward at all so what I
think we need to be able to do is to not
only change the formula for success to
help us to be able to focus upon this
idea that if we prioritize happiness it
will then raise our success rates but
also a recognition that is something
that we actually have to be conscious
about on a daily on a daily basis
there's something that actually requires
effort it requires training it requires
us to be all focus our attention on this
and we do so I think the thing that we
oftentimes think is that if people get
happy they'll stop working hard or that
happy people are unintelligent and what
we're finding is just the opposite
I think it's the most counterintuitive
thing we found which is happiness
actually raises an individual's
intelligence and their success rates we
find that is you know that the happy
people happy people aren't always the
smartest people we know that there's
I've met tons of people that are very
successful and not happy and people that
are extremely intelligent and not happy
so we might assume that those two things
are divorced but now what we really
realized in the science is that both of
those individuals are actually
underperforming what their brain is
actually capable of and if we have more
role models or companies and schools of
individuals are positive and infect
other people with that positivity
rippling out through those mirror neuron
networks not only can we raise the
levels of happiness and engagement or
our schools and companies again but will
actually rate their levels of successes
as well